valérie bénaïm on est 1er juin oui
irlandais 1er juin premier jour du mois
donc j'ai envie que chacun pour cette ce
début d'émission me raconte sa première
fois mais ça peut être son premier sas à
sa première fois avec une fille a peut
être son premier jour de travail grâce à
sa première embrouille avec quelqu'un
valérie bénaïm c'est quoi alors ce qui
me vient à l'esprit c'est mon premier
jour au ski catastrophique non mais
alors vous avez choper d'ailleurs le
prof de ski qui s'applique david qui
était canadien
je suis totalement nul au ski mais ça
m'a pas empêché de choper effectivement
j'ai la balle à l'entrée où il avait un
très beau compter ses premiers jours au
ski c'était dans les années 80 et donc à
l'époque on avait des combinaisons fluo
vous souvenez un peu gris et
malheureusement l'amiénois vraiment de
quoi elle était orange et surtout elle
avait ce côté matières toile cirée way
est donc comme je ne savais pas ce qui
est jeu sera sans moi l'histoire au delà
bildt
évidemment je ne sais pas ce qui est
donc je choix du choix divers mais je ne
m'en fais pas je choisis
alors oui et le problème c'est que avec
cette combinaison impossible de
s'arrêter
ce qui fait que j'ai été applaudi par
toute la piste qui devait faire au moins
je sais pas un kilomètre de kilomètres
on sait rien sur les fesses on n'est en
hurlant en essayant de m'arrêter avec
mes skis
or il en mange des choses et je glisse
je glisse julie s'accordent tout le
monde applaudit et jetez la star de la
station eh bien écoutez une belle et ça
me fait beaucoup de peine de démarrer
cette émission pour cette année
malheureusement pas ça vous tombe sur la
gueule
moi ce qui me vient à l'esprit du coup
c'est ma première fois ma vraie première
non bah oui a du coup voilà carouge
avait de solides
voilà alors allez-y alors votre première
fois alors là je vous demande et je veux
le silence et concentration
j'étais en terminale non mais c'est
mignon j'étais en terminale et j'étais
très très nul en maths
donc j'avais pris option maths il
fallait absolument que j'ai le niveau
pour avoir au moins la moyenne donc mes
parents m'ont forcé à prendre des cours
je croyais avait plié forcé à coucher et
la cour cours particuliers de maths est
donc évidemment au début j'ai fait la
gueule j'ai dit attends c'est bon j'ai
pas que ça à faire laissez moi je vais
me débrouiller etc ils ont insisté
pendant une partie de l'année
et finalement le jour est arrivé où le
prof de maths particulier petit
étudiants de 19 20 en maths sup
compagnie bon moi j'ai été en bac
littéraire option maths très bon jour
sous la garde de plus que moi et quand
j'ai vu arriver chez moi j'ai tout de
suite compris qu'on allait faire un peu
plus que des additions né à bascons
terminal 2g les additions
et caroline ithurbide total est en titre
soit j'ai déconné sur 10 pouces si je
crois que j'ai mes 14 à maxime thoor la
pape allemand alors là de recherche
alors là c'est la première fois où j'ai
acheté des bouquins seul j'ai été au
départ
alors oui alors c'est mon premier râteau
mon premier râteau - avril avec une
fille c'était il ya deux ans avec une
très jolie fille appelée comment vous le
pré de tana regarde jamais eu de râteaux
avant ça veut dire venant jamais
bringand jamais non jamais le combien de
filles à peu près 3 4 vous êtes toujours
des histoires très sérieuse mais c'est
beau mais j'aime bien ce mec de chez
vous j'aime bien et que les conflits
margot margot à armissan et votre maman
va ranger de police et une moto terne
avionnais la gougoutte ascenseur un peu
la barre en chef du site est arrêté au
vu de feu alors oui un peu de baranger
le coup elle me dit c'est une fille très
doux vers l'asie ok je lui dis prend
qu'on le resteront que tu sois tu es
bien sûr elle m'a invité dans un bar
avant moi qui ne boit pas d'alcool j'ai
passé une excellente soirée avec mon
verre d'eau en tout cas la soirée se
passe bien deuxième rendez vous au
cinéma puissance remember dior justement
si vous avez décroché tapez pas de mise
et il faut l'embrasser pour le deuxième
rendez vous donc j'étais focalisé sur ça
j'écoute est quasiment pas ce qu'il
disait et j'avais vraiment l'impression
de vous de voir l'embrasser on termine
je paye l'addition
on longe la rue on prend le métro à
opéra et dans le métro opéra ça pue
souvent les lésés duels et les égouts
pardon et là je me mets à l'embrasser
c'est à dire une deux trois secondes et
vous de la troisième seconde elle sortit
ali qu'est ce que tu fais est dit non
mais je n'étais pas du tout prêt pour
faire ça et depuis ce jour
pourquoi je ne suis pas beau on drague
parce que ça m'a totalement tétanisée
donc voilà la petite histoire c'était
mon premier râteau et il ya deux ans
c'était plutôt sympathique car c'est un
peu ripoux alors christophe carrière
est-ce que c'est intéressant bien oui
tout est intéressant c'est ma première
fois à la télé ah bon sur votre choix
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est mon premier coup de gueule
dois je vous ai amené les photos vous
avez les photos ouais c'est des photos
que on avait alésien diffusé à envoyer
les photos ont régi vous dormez c'est
l'histoire de carrière s'affoler photo
et deux photos de moi petit qu'on les
avait on les avait déjà passé moi c'est
nos sols enfants qui pour faire faites
entrer l'accusé
[Rires]
sur la tête de ma mère il avait l'enfant
et où ce oui on dirait un peu si mme b b
non mais c'est vrai mais l'enfant
souffre mais francis heaulme si votre
boss de calmont reprises chez qui le
poupe et tuba voulez que je vous dise
[Applaudissements]
ah les benjamins le choix c'est la
première fois avec une vie non non non
non
et en fait d'abord la fois j'étais très
stressée je vois là j'ai déjà bien quel
âge
ouais j'ai pas 14 ans pensent à tort
c'est à quel âge vous la première fois
perd 13 13 ans ah oui après j'ai une
longue traversée du désert
ah oui j'ai beaucoup progressé au
travail manuel merci livraison vous quel
âge vous m'a dit ah oui c'est vrai avec
thomas 15 entre au moins 28 jours dans
trois mois 28 jours alors vous dont 14
en tant que prisonnier 14 ans et j'avais
peur de ne pas être à la hauteur
donc d'où la chanson être à la hauteur
et donc j'ai appelé mon père je dis papa
et qu'est ce que je pourrais me prendre
pour être plus en forme quoi il a dû
être un pc avec votre père jean pierre
castaldi a dit qu'il avait fauté tout
paramédicaux n'écoute il ya un truc qui
marche très bien si tu prends le tabasco
non sauf mais ce qu'on en fait lui l'a
pas vu il a mis sur le schengen
[Applaudissements]
hélas hélas normalement verser les mines
activées opposition sur le dos un piment
d'espelette
aux élus tabasco évidemment au bout de
deux à une seconde et demi j'avais la
quête en feu marché est le plus grave
c'est qu'après j'ai mis la faune est en
feu de l'autre ah oui ah oui ça a été un
drame
en france j'ai réussi comme ça m'a
appelé les pompiers c'était c'était
pénible s'était jetée pdb bon on termine
par une bien belle anecdote